[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents ce point
[Musique]
à la une une marche à des libertés
contre l'extrême droite dans plusieurs
villes de france et le grand écart des
chiffres de participation plus de trente
sept mille manifestants au total dans
neuf mille à paris selon le ministère de
l'intérieur 150 milles dont 70 milles
dans la capitale selon les organisateurs
moments marquants le leader de la france
insoumise visé par un g de farine
l'auteur présumé a été arrêté pour
violences volontaires et placés en garde
à vue en fin de journée en algérie
visiblement les électeurs ne sont pas
allés voter massivement pour les
législatives anticipées
les premières depuis la chute
d'abdelaziz bouteflika à la mi journée
on a noté un faible taux de
participation autour de 10% selon
l'instance électorale du pays le
mouvement du irak et l'opposition ont
lancé un appel au boycott du scrutin
[Musique]
deuxième jour du g7 au royaume uni en
présence de joe biden lui emmanuel
macron se sont entretenus cet après midi
à carbis des les deux présidents se sont
félicités d'une reprise de la
coopération entre l'union européenne et
les etats unis au moment d'affronter
leurs défis communs
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france dans toute la
france une grande marche à des libertés
aujourd'hui plus de trente sept mille
manifestants dont un fils à paris selon
le ministère de l'intérieur
et selon les organisateurs ils étaient
150 milles dont 70 milles à paris sur
place le leader de la france insoumise a
été en farine et l'auteur présumé a été
arrêté pour violences volontaires et
placés en garde à vue
on fait le point avec notre reporter
natacha pierre asac l'image peut être à
retenir de cette marche des libertés
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être celle de
jean-luc mélenchon et d'autres députés
de gauche enfarinée en début de
manifestation
on en sait plus sur le profil de l'an
farine heures entre guillemets après
avoir déclaré qu'il était de gauche il a
fini par avouer qu'il était
souverainiste et en creusant un petit
peu on s'est rendu compte qu'il était
youtuber et qu'il partageait plus tôt et
des idées d'extrême droite au micro
d'rtl france il explique son geste
un ras-le-bol vis-à-vis de ces gens en
fait tous politiques confondues 1 de
marine le pen à jean luc mélenchon
personne n'écoute vraiment le peuple ils
ne défendent qu'une caste bourgeoise et
joue sur des petits des petits des
petits thème complètement secondaire
mais qui ne vont jamais des le les gens
il faudrait se rassembler et à arrêter
de parler notamment d'immigration
l'immigration c'est terry parce que la
gauche n'en parle jamais la droite ne
parle que de ça où est ce que je veux
dire il ya un vrai problème
et au final c'est la seule démarcation
aujourd'hui entre la gauche et la droite
il faut être de bon sens il ya des
choses qu'on peut faire pour que tout le
monde aille mieux mais on ne les fait
pas je suis vivant tout va bien préfère
relativiser jean luc mélenchon du côté
de ses soutiens à la france en soumises
ont dénoncé un comportement
représentatif du climat délétère actuel
on écoute danièle obono député la france
en somistes on voit bien que les forces
réactionnaires conservatrice voire
fasciste ou au proto fasciste on grave
la confiance et font preuve de violence
de violence verbale de violence en ligne
et compris de violences physiques il ya
quelques jours c'est le président de la
république qui a été agressée alors
c'est l'expression fait de la
radicalisation de ces secteurs-là des
secteurs militants des secteurs violent
et c'est ce sur quoi nous alertons et
donc et donc c'est aussi le sens d'être
là et de dire voilà nous on recule pas
et l'autre point important que cette
marche des libertés c'est son influence
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants et y avoir participé parmi
des représentants politiques syndicaux
et associatifs il était essentiel pour
eux d'être présents pour dénoncer des
idées d'extrême droite qui se sont
banalisées au fil des années des idées
qui représente selon eux un réel danger
pour la république beaucoup de dodo de
français ont un comportement et c'est ça
qu'on veut dénoncer quoi il sans
trembler en train de tomber le piège de
l'extrême droite on seront sèches
d'extrême droite on se comporte comme
l'extrême droite et c'est tout ça qu'on
va dépenser en disant stop stop
l'extrême droite c'est pas le modèle le
front national c'est pas le modèle tous
ses polémistes comme toute la clique on
rend compte sur ses news faut arrêter
c'est pas le modèle c'est pas le format
ces gens là ils sont là pour pour semer
le trouble
ils veulent diviser la société française
mais ils ne réussiront pas l'extrême
droite ne réussira pas on continuera à
se battre en france et des gens très
bien il ya de belles valeurs
il faut se battre pour çà te france là
et non pas se prendre de la division
pourquoi les émigrés bientôt nous
peut-être on sera immigrés avec le
réchauffement climatique est alors dans
ce cas là on fera quoi pourra que nous
tabasser aussi commandes comme on traite
les immigrés qui arrivent qui fuient
leur pays
pour les conditions dans lesquelles ils
vivent à manifestation qui s'est
déroulée dans le calme et la bonne
humeur avec il faut le souligner une
absence de dispositif policier
d'encadrement direct du cortège c'est
assez rare pour être souligné on le sait
que c'est presque devenu la règle au
cours des trois dernières années
notamment pour donner l'exemple des
manifestations de gilet jaune comme quoi
il est possible encore aujourd'hui de
manifester sans que ça dégénère en
algérie les bureaux de vote ferment dans
une heure des législatives anticipées
boudé par les électeurs ici le vote du
premier ministre abdelaziz djerrad cet
été à alger ce matin à la mi-journée le
taux de participation nationale étaient
de 10 % selon le président de l'autorité
nationale indépendante des élections
un scrutin marqué par l'appel au boycott
des partisans du irak certains d'entre
eux et des journalistes ont d'ailleurs
été arrêtés ces derniers jours puis
libérés ont fait le point avec notre
envoyé spécial en algérie bassam shelly
les bureaux de vote sont ouverts depuis
8 heures ici en algérie et le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il ne semble
pas y avoir foule pour ces premières
législatives depuis le soulèvement
populaire inédit du 22 février 2019 née
du rejet d'un cinquième mandat de
l'ancien président abdelaziz bouteflika
quelques 24 millions d'algériens sont
appelés aujourd'hui à élire 407 députés
de l'assemblée populaire nationale pour
un mandat de cinq ans ces algériens peu
nombreux aujourd'hui dans les bureaux de
vote doivent choisir parmi plus de 1500
listes non plus de la moitié s'affiche
comme indépendants écoutez ces algériens
qu'on a pu interviewer à la sortie des
bureaux de vote
c'est très important parce que
la première des choses on va falloir
changer et faire les jeunes les nouveaux
jeunes qui sont plus diplômées et qu'ils
ont plus d'expérience et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut voter c'est une des choses
qui est plus importante
voilà c'est pour ça que je veux j'ai
toujours voté
j'ai toujours voté en plus de sa queue
je suis de la région de nice je suis
niçois mais par contre tu bloques est là
depuis un an et demi alors il va falloir
que je vote c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
un échange je suis inscrit et voilà je
viens beauté déjà
voter c'est un devoir de citoyen et nous
avons des haies
des droits mais nous avons aussi des
déboires auxquels on doit répondre en
tant que citoyenne et puis
la chaise vide n'a jamais n'a jamais
donné de bons résultats il faut être là
pour pouvoir choisir que d'avoir à être
un supporter ce qui n'a pas été choisie
bat toujours on garde toujours le petit
espoir qui nous reste voilà parce
qu'avec dans toute l'algérie l'ouvrir
nouvelles pendant là on vient tout petit
espoir qu'on a pour voter on va voir
pour la suite puisque c'est passé on a
passé par des périodes très très
difficile pendant vingt ans qu'on n'a
pas réalisé avec ces scrutins
à l'issue d'une campagne sans public
pour cause de coronavirus et les partis
pro-gouvernementaux ont appelé à
participer en force au scrutin tandis
que l'irak qui réclame un changement
radical du système de gouvernance et
l'opposition démocratique et dénoncent
une mascarade électorale et appellent au
boycott le gouvernement bien déterminée
à maintenir sa feuille de route
électoraliste s'attend d'emblée un fort
taux d'abstention comme celui lors des
présidentielles de 2010 9 et du
référendum constitutionnel de 2020 mais
espère toutefois un taux de
participation entre 40 et 50%
ben hassen chébili qui est également
parti à la rencontre des algériens qui
ont fait le choix de ne pas voter
reportage avec car le récit de maxime
curatif
loin de l'agitation de la capitale et
l'adie lassouli veille sur ses tomates
ses pommes de terre et son verger sur
ses terres mises à disposition par le
gouvernement dans les années 80 le
départ de l'ex président bouteflika a
fait naître en lui un espoir de
changement pour l'algérie mais plus de
deux ans plus tard l'excitation a laissé
place à la déception sentiment qu'il a
poussé aujourd'hui à boycotter les
élections législatives anticipées
on l'a pas vu le changement et à cause
de ça je vais pas aller voter parce que
je ne crois pas à ces élections je crois
pas ce changement est à 220
détenus d'opinion c'est à dire si on
veut vraiment aller vers un pays
démocratique on emprisonne pas des gens
pour leurs opinions
on n'est pas arrivé à à concrétiser
notre idéal le rêve le rêve d'un
algérien qui qui vit dans une république
démocratique et populaire
nous on cherche c'est réellement elle
est où la démocratie dans cette
république
cette déception semble avoir gagné une
grande partie de la population
algérienne principalement chez celles
qui a choisi de l'exprimer dans la rue à
travers le mouvement du l'irak médecin à
la retraite
djamel eddine ou lan est devenu depuis
deux ans militants et activistes engagés
pendant plus de trente ans il a réalisé
pour le ministère algérien de la santé
mais aussi pour l' oms et l'onu des
campagnes de prévention
les affiches de sensibilisation d'antan
ont laissé place à de nouvelles beaucoup
plus engagé hostiles au gouvernement en
place il y à une répression terrible
c'est ces dernières semaines plus de
deux mille arrestations de militants
deux activistes pacifiques des gens qui
n'ont rien fait d'illégal
c'était le fait seulement d'exprimer
pacifiquement leur opposition à la
feuille de route de ce pouvoir
il ya aussi l'aspect de des médias c'est
une c si tu veux c'est une honte ce qui
se passe en ce moment dans les médias
qui sont contrôlés par le pouvoir
dans ce climat je pense que c'est ça
serait vraiment ignoble de notre part de
participer à ces élections un possible
boycott doublé d'un rejet de la chose
politique que le politologue brahim
zitouni explique par l'incapacité de
l'état algérien à opérer les réformes
nécessaires aux aspirations populaires
en réalité déception et xi excitation
sont les deux faces d'une même pièce
c'est le renvoi à des explications
idéologique d'un mouvement social
en fait nous sommes dans un paradoxe un
mouvement social de cette puissance 13
millions 14 millions d'algériens dans
les rues toutes régions confondues amène
forcément à une extraordinaire
politisation du mouvement social et
ce n'est pas l'un vers ce donc il y a
une vraie conscience politique
mais il n'y a pas de tradition partizan
ont créé tout simplement parce que
trente ans d'un système autoritaire au
fait fuir les élites capables d'encadrer
les jeunes
le choix des 407 membres de l'assemblée
populaire nationale suscite
interrogations et incertitudes qu'ils
soient votants ou partisans du boycott
il appartient à nouveau aux algériens de
déterminer les contours de cette
nouvelle scène politique post bouteflika
loin de faire l'unanimité
écoutez l'analyse du politologue riadh
sidaoui les directeurs du carapace le
centre arabe de recherches d'analystes
politiques et sociales selon lui la
libération de trois opposants cette nuit
et un message d'apaisement pour les
électeurs et surtout pour les jeunes
si nos ouvertures politiques ou à
baisser la tension et pour donner chance
aux ir mais surtout à cette jeunesse
cette jeunesse
n'oublions pas aussi lire notre cinéma
ce logis il est comme les autres
arrivent le phénomène biologique et
politique et le tribalisme en algérie ce
tribalisme à gauche il ya ça veut dire
des régions des réunions ils votent au
nord ni aux enfants à pau nord est d'une
logique politique mais juste dans leurs
enfants dans le tribalisme aussi jouent
un rôle sociologique assez important
surtout dans les villages et dans les
doigts et à la campagne
le deuxième jour du j'ai fait cette
première rencontre entre la france et
les etats-unis manuel macro 1 et joe
biden se sont entretenus fait après midi
à cardiff bay les deux présidents ont
salué la reprise de la coopération entre
l'union européenne et les etats unis
je vous propose de les écouter
oui nous devons faire face à cette
pandémie le covic 19 pandémique
nous devons faire face à de nombreux
défis à de nombreuses crises au
changement climatique a un métier et
pour tous ces problèmes nous avons
besoin de coopération et je pense que
c'est formidable que le président
américain fasse partie du club et qu'il
soit très désir de coopérer et je pense
que ce que vous démontrez c'est que le
leadership c'est un partenariat d le
sheep esparza chez les états unis comme
je les ai déjà dit nous sommes de retour
les etats unis sont de retour nous
sommes très très attaché à la cohésion
de l'otan et pour ma part je pense que
l'union européenne est une entité
incroyablement forte et dynamique qui a
beaucoup à voir avec la capacité de
l'europe occidentale à gérer non
seulement ces problèmes économiques mais
aussi à fournir l'arrière-plan et le
soutien de l'otan
donc oui nous sommes très favorables
très favorable
le g7 est son épine dossier celui du
break site avec la question nord
irlandaise est derrière les sourires
affichés des dirigeants beaucoup de
crispation réalité les explications avec
walid ben attash un ménage à trois qui
accapare la tenue d'un g7 à l'accent
très post corexit bruxelles d'un côté
londres de l'autre le royaume uni au
centre des attentions
là notre camp celui des plus grands
dirigeants de la planète en quête
d'unité le président français en tête
par la voie de l'elysée
emmanuel macron s'est dit prêt à se
rapprocher du royaume uni à la seule
condition que les britanniques respecte
la parole donnée aux européens et le
cadre défini par les accords break site
la chancelière allemande préconise de
trouver l une solution pragmatique en
ligne de mire les engagements
économiques de londres envers l'irlande
du nord sous la pression de bruxelles la
province britannique est resté dans le
marché de la zone euro afin d'éviter une
frontière terrestre avec sa voisine du
sud la république d'irlande membres de
l'union européenne 2
1973 le président américain joe biden
d'origine irlandaise tout comme lui et
eux ne souhaitons pas faire renaître les
vieux démons et éviter un conflit
sanglant l'accord du vendredi saint et
la paix sur l'île d'irlande sont
primordiaux nous avons négocié un
protocole qui le préserve signés et
ratifiés par le royaume uni et bruxelles
nous voulons les meilleures relations
possibles avec le royaume uni
les deux parties doivent mettre en
oeuvre ce sur quoi nous nous sommes mis
d'accord il y à une unité européenne
complète à ce sujet une union européenne
qui contrôlent ainsi avec minutie les
marchandises qui transitent par la mer
d'irlande
le premier ministre britannique demande
à bruxelles de faire preuve d'un peu
plus de souplesse sous peine par exemple
de compromettre l'approvisionnement
n'est nord irlandais en saucisses
anglaise une guerre de viande réfrigérée
qui ne refroidit pas l' enthousiasme des
dirigeants européens
heureux à l'idée de travailler ensemble
enfin la bonne humeur ne règle pas tout
boris johnson a averti que le royaume
uni n'hésitera pas à passer outre
certaines dispositions du protocole nord
irlandais en évoquant l'article 16 de
l'accord du break site qui l'y
autorisent
en cas de graves difficultés économiques
sociétales ou environnemental en marge
du g7 une manifestation en soutien à la
palestine à londres les participants
sont venus dénoncer la coopération
militaire des membres du g7 avec israël
hier encore un adolescent palestinien a
été tué par des tirs de soldats
israéliens lors de heurts en marge de
manifestations contre la colonisation en
cisjordanie occupée
temps fort de la visite européenne de
joe biden se fera sans doute mercredi
prochain sa rencontre avec son homologue
russe vladimir poutine les deux chefs
d'état ont fait savoir leur volonté de
réchauffer les relations bilatérales
malgré les nombreux points de discorde
on voit cela avec hélène mascagni
monsieur le président quel est votre
message à poutine
je vous le dirai une fois que je l'aurai
délivrer le président américain reste
évasif sur les sujets qui seront abordés
avec le président russe ce mercredi mais
dans la tente du face à face
l'ambiance s'annonce électrique entre
les deux dirigeants depuis une semaine
vladimir poutine et joe biden multiplie
les petites piques ce vendredi lors
d'une interview accordée à la chaîne
américaine nbc interrogé sur la sortie
cinglante de joe biden il ya près d'un
mois
lorsqu'il avait taxé vladimir poutine de
tueurs ce dernier a répondu sans détour
mais ce n'est pas monsieur le président
avec vous un tueur président que vous
avez aimé ce héros pour écouter durant
ma carrière je me suis habitué aux
attaques venant de tous les côtés pour
de nombreuses raisons à des attaques de
différentes qualités et finesse
rien de cela ne m'étonne les personnes
avec qui nous coopérons et nous
disputons sur la scène internationale et
nous même ne sommes pas de jeunes mariés
nous ne nous leurrons pas amour et
amitié pour l'éternité
nous sommes des partenaires et sous
certains angles
nous sommes rivaux lors de cette
interview
vladimir poutine a aussi dit espérer que
joe biden se montrerait moins impulsif
que son prédécesseur donald trump
pourtant l'ex vice président de barack
obama ne semble pas vouloir adoucir la
politique américaine à l'égard de la
russie
dès son arrivée au royaume uni pour sa
toute première tournée européenne
joe biden a prévenu moscou l'ambition
américaine est bien de consolider les
alliances démocratique de washington
face aux menaces russe et chinoise
j'ai été clair sur le fait que les états
unis répondront de manière forte est
significative
si le gouvernement russe s'engagent dans
des activités nuisibles
nous avons déjà démontré qu'il y a des
conséquences si on veut violer la
souveraineté des démocraties aux états
unis en europe et ailleurs
je vais être clair sur le fait que
l'alliance transatlantique restera un
support essentiel pour le royaume uni
l'europe et les états unis
je vais m'assurer que cela ne fasse
aucun doute que les etats-unis se
lèveront pour défendre leurs valeurs les
plus profondes et leurs intérêts
fondamentaux
ce rendez-vous à l'initiative de
washington et pour les états unis un
moyen d'exprimer ses attentes à l'égard
de moscou et les sujets de discorde ne
manquent pas à l'appel accusations
d'ingérence dans les élections
américaines cyberattaque présumée contre
des entreprises d'outre-atlantique
le sort de l'opposant russe alexeï
navalni ou encore la question de
l'ukraine ce dialogue de titan quelle
qu'en soit l'issue sera scrutée par la
communauté internationale ce mercredi à
l'heure où les grandes puissances
tentent de se repositionner sur un
échiquier mondial remodelée par la
pandémie de kovy 19
un mot sur la vaccination maintenant on
compte 30 millions de primo vacciner
selon les autorités et mais on atteint
un léger ralentissement au niveau de la
prise de rendez-vous dans l'hexagone
alors comment l'expliquez côté jean paul
stahl infectiologues au chu de grenoble
alpes on arrive maintenant à vers les
populations étaient les plus hésitante
voire les plus réfractaires donc cela il
va falloir faire preuve de pédagogie
pour essayer de les convaincre
la deuxième raison c'est que bat tout le
monde y est juste raison le nombre de
cas est en train de diminuer
et donc la tentation est sans doute de
se dire bon allez c'est plus la peine de
me faire vacciner puisque la maladie
n'existe plus ce qu'il faut mais
l'apparence est là et puis il ya aussi
sans doute un calcul beaucoup plus
trivial qui est de se dire oui mais si
je me vaccine maintenant ma deuxième
dose et ça pendant des vacances donc là
ça va être un problème pour moi et je
vais repoussé ont vacciné après les
vacances l'aprem en retour de vacances
donc tout ça doit sans doute être un
petit peu mêlée pour pour expliquer ce
ralentissement la ville de monthey nos
dans l'yonne sous le choc au lendemain
d'un énième féminicide une femme de 32
ans a été tué hier par son ex conjoint
ce dernier était déjà connu de la
justice pour violences conjugales
un fait tragique qui survient un peu
plus d'un mois après l'assassinât d'une
mère de famille brûlée vive à mérignac
en gironde depuis des dispositions
pourtant été prises elles les
explications devant les ministères de
l'intérieur avec katia technique
chez inès da ou d'une jeune femme de 31
ans a été assassiné en pleine rue le 4
mai dernier à mérignac immolé par son
mari dont elle était séparée
face à ce nouveau féminicide un de plus
en france un rapport a été rédigé et
rendu le 9 juin
le document met en avant des
dysfonctionnements extrêmement grave
un millefeuille d'erreur d'oublier de
négligence et ce alors que la lutte
contre les violences envers les femmes a
été déclarée grande cause du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron comme de nombreux
autres l'assassinât de chahinez aurait
pu être évité son ex compagnon avait
déjà été incarcéré pour des violences à
son encontre
il avait interdiction de s'approcher de
son domicile et elle avait de nouveau
porté plainte contre lui en mars après
qu'il a une fois de plus agressé la
jeune femme avait bien tout tenté pour
être protégés et pourtant les 27 pages
de ce document pointe une série
d'erreurs accablante
à commencer par un manque d'évaluation
de la dangerosité de son ex-compagnon
dénoncés par le rapport
condamné en juin 2020 il tente d'abord
de recontacter la victime pendant son
séjour en prison
malgré sa dangerosité potentielle
l'ex-compagnon libéré en décembre le 15
mars dernier
il tend un piège à chainel l'étranglent
et la frappe
la jeune femme qui vient alors
d'échapper à la mort se rend au
commissariat
un policier remplit alors une grille
d'évaluation du danger et une fille
d'évaluation de la victime problème
elles sont quasi illisible le greffe en
demande donc une autre version policiers
qui ne sera jamais renvoyé quant à la
plainte de la jeune femme elle n'est
même pas transmise au parquet l'homme
est tout de même recherché par la police
les agents se renseigne auprès des
services pénitentiaires de probation
mais ceci ne les avertissent pas qu'ils
ont rendez vous avec lui dans les jours
à venir alors qu'il aurait pu être
interpellé à ce moment là il est alors
question de donner le téléphone grave
danger à shane est dans une réunion du
18 mars
mais finalement cette décision n'est pas
prise son compagnon se rend de son
propre chef au commissariat pour une
autre raison un peu plus tard et alors
qu'il devrait être arrêté aucune
connexion des fêtes avec son avis de
recherche
la suite était quasiment écrite un mois
plus tard il tue sa femme comme chahinez
90 femmes sont mortes sous les coups de
leur compagnon de leur ex conjoint en
2020 et déjà cinquante et une en
1021 le bilan du grenelle des violences
conjugales mais pour le moment pas
satisfaisant malgré les dispositions
annoncées
peut-être fallait-il cette énième drame
pour que le gouvernement identifie les
problèmes de coordination et les failles
du système
il vient d'annoncer six nouvelles
mesures 3000 téléphone graves dangers
seront mises à disposition des
juridictions d'ici début 2010 22 contre
1324 actuellement le recours au bracelet
anti rapprochement sera renforcée 96
sont actifs aujourd'hui et en fichier
des auteurs de violences conjugales va
être créé une instance de suivi
judiciaire des situations individuelles
va être mise en place
elle coordonnera police-justice services
pénitentiaires et associations est
désormais 100% des plaintes devant être
prise bien qualifiés transmise au
parquet le contrôle et la détention des
armes à feu seront renforcées une
instance nationale dédiée aux violences
faites aux femmes et aux filles va être
créé pour fédérer les associations
un comité de suivi des mesures annoncées
dans le cadre du grenelle des violences
conjugales se chargera d'examiner la
bonne marche de l'ensemble reste
maintenant à éviter les nombreuses
erreurs humaines et le manque de
détermination des autorités rencontrées
par les femmes qui tentent de se
protéger de leurs bourreaux un mot
encore sur les élections à régionales le
premier tour aura lieu le 20 juin
prochain
europe ecologie les verts a réuni ses
troupes ce samedi dans le 20e
arrondissement de paris pour philippe
bourrier achi candidate dans le val de
marne
c'était l'occasion de prouver que les
verts sont désormais capables de
gouverner écouter le sens aujourd'hui
que l'aspiration et on l'a vu dans le
dernier résultat aux européennes et aux
municipales cette vague verte cette
déferlante verte arriver progressivement
elle à la porte du couloir faisons
là tout de suite pas le test mais
prouvons et démontrons que nous sommes
durs
nous sommes vers mais nous sommes mûrs
pour pouvoir gouverner pour pouvoir
diriger nous faisons dans des villes de
façon spectaculaire
beaucoup sont surpris nous sommes sous
le feu de deux plaintes critiquer c'est
normal lorsque vous êtes le challenger
vous fait un petit peu tiré dessus à
chaque à chaque demi l'événement mais
c'est parce que nous représentons le
danger de la transition la fin de ce
monde néolibéral est l'alternative au
hold up des populistes dont contre la
mecque libéral et le bloc des populismes
et un troisième voie c'est celle de
l'écologie et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en direct dans 30 minutes
rester avec nous sur rtl france
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un programme